the idea here here's my
i'm speaking for myself um you know my
take on
on blm um
the idea behind its creation i feel was
a great idea
by the founders they co-opted the
the idea for martin luther king's what
they did
um martin luther king wanted to put the
national spotlight
on the plight of black bus riders in uh
in montgomery alabama with you know rosa
parks and the bus drivers and all that
kind of stuff
making people sit in the back of the bus
and and being mistreated
uh because that kind of thing was going
on in montgomery for a long
time and in southern states for a long
time but the rest of the country was not
aware
so martin the king came with the idea of
let's let's make sure everybody sees
this
we're gonna do it we're gonna do a major
boycott of the bus system
and put in the national spotlight and
maybe that will help change it
and it did so the founders of blm
decided hey you know let's do that same
thing
let's let's put the plight of black men
in the national spotlight
because what was happening was black men
for lack of a better term were being
murdered
by white police officers absolutely for
holding their cell phone their wallet or
whatever
whether they were innocent or guilty
black men got to go to their grave
white men in the same in the same
predicament
either got to go home or go to jail some
got to go to jail via burger king
you know dylann roof right dylan roof
dylan rufus was the white supremacist oh
yes shot of the black church yes
you remember him being taken to burger
king yes i do remember that yeah what's
up with that
okay you got somebody like eric garner
remember eric garner
eric garner was the original i can't
breathe guy up on staten island new york
who was selling loose cigarettes and
they threw him on the ground and choked
him on the on the camera
to death a guy
did the same thing like that same thing
that happened to george floyd
cigarettes yeah okay eric garner look
him up eric garner
all right he was on the sidewalk of um
staten island
selling loose cigarettes it's illegal to
sell tobacco without a license
right it's like you can't sell liquor
without a license right all right
so he's selling loose cigarettes for 50
cents or whatever he's selling them for
and the cops bust him and six of them
like jumped on him slammed him down to
the ground
sat on his back and choked him to death
with their hands with his hand yeah the
one cop
and he kept saying i can't breathe i
can't breathe i can't breathe
he just kept choking him while
somebody's filming it on the on the cell
phone
and choked the life right out of him
right on camera all right
and the cops got acquitted okay
um should eric garner have been
um arrested sure he's breaking the law
right you know giving us a citation or
arrest him whatever
all right and then let the court decide
what the punishment should be
not the cops george floyd
um well eric garner was not committing a
violent crime
he was breaking the law yes but it was
not a violent
crime you understand he wasn't like
shooting anybody
or raping anybody right right it was it
was a non-violent crime just selling
loose cigarettes
right all right uh sort of like stealing
the newspaper out of out of the
newspaper box
nonviolent crime okay george floyd
he is accused of allegedly passing a
counterfeit 20
bill we will never know
if that's what he was doing or not
because he never had his day in court
um did he know that he had a fake 20
it's the clerk's job who called the
police he did the right thing the clerk
did
to look at the money and recognize
something that's counterfeit
now we never saw the 20 bills we don't
know if the clerk made a mistake or
didn't make a mistake
but in the event uh the clerk thought
this 20 bill looked
odd like it was counterfeit so he did
the right thing
he called the police all right the
police came and killed george floyd
for passing a 20 bill
if let's let's say the 20 dollar bill
was fake
all right let's say it was fake the
question then becomes
did george floyd know he had a fake 20
bill on him um we don't know that
okay he could have um look here
here's my wallet
i got some money here here's a 50
here's a hundred here's some 20s
right all right i don't know if this is
a fake 20 or not
okay if i go to 7-eleven and let's let's
say i don't i don't have this money
all i got is a hundred dollar bill here
right and i buy some whatever
when i get my change i'm gonna have some
20s right right out of this hundred
of course i i'm gonna put it in my
wallet
i don't know if one of those 20s is fake
or not so then a couple days later i go
to another store
and i give the clerk he goes oh this is
a thing i'm gonna call the cops
okay now if i knew it was a fake and i'm
doing it yeah i'm wrong
but if i don't know you know it's not my
job
to know what to look for uh on a 20 bill
to know if it's fake or not
right but it is a clerk's job so he did
the right thing if you thought it was
fake
but the court would have determined if i
was doing this intentionally
or did i really not know and i'm and i'm
passing the 20 bill right just like i
don't know if anything in here is fake
that hundred dollar bill might be fake
as far as i know okay
um that's why you know when you go to
the store you know they pulled up to the
light and they put a mark on it or
something
i don't do that with my money right i
don't know what to look for
okay did george floyd actually know that
he had a fake 20
bill we don't know that we will never
know that because he's dead
he could have been we could have given
him a polygraph test did you know that
that money was fake you know or we could
we could
have determined that in court all right
but he never got that chance what he did
was he committed
uh if that thing was fake it was
a non-violent crime he did not deserve
to die for that
he should have been cited or arrested or
whatever
and then let the court determine you
know did he know
that he was making a mistake and or or
was or did he
or was he doing this intentionally
trying to get away with with laundering
money or something
right okay but they killed him for a
non-violent crime
that will that we will never know what
he knew all right
but yet these non-violent crimes
send black men to their graves but
somebody who walks into a black church
armed to the teeth and murders nine
black people
conducting bible study gets to go to
burger king
that's why things like black lives
matter exist so everybody can see the
difference
but the national spotlight on that oh
you sell loose cigarettes
you get choked to death you possibly
pass
a fake 20 bill you get choked to death
you hold your wallet up in the air
you get shot because the cop thinks it's
a gun
but you you kill nine black people and
you tell the cops you're hungry
they take you to burger king you know
that that's what we see
as black people that's why black lives
matter is created
now my problem which is a great idea
my problem with black lives matter is
they should have centralized they are
decentralized
there is no central black lives matter
you you called it right it is a movement
it's not an
organization an organization you pay
your dues to
you become a member et cetera et cetera
right right have meetings um
black lives matter is is decentralized a
decentralized movement
there is no one president there are no
chapters of black lives matter
there are factions chapters all belong
to the same
headquarters okay okay like for example
you take the naacp
uh the boy scouts of america the red
cross
these are all centralized organizations
where there's one president
there's a headquarters and policy is
created
at headquarters and disseminated to all
the chapters
all over the country so every chapter is
on the same page
right you have policy everybody adheres
to that policy
black lives matter is not like that
there is no headquarters
one president there are all these
different factions
because the the founders did not want to
centralize
they wanted it to be organic they didn't
even trademark the name
so they don't have any any uh any
ownership of the name black lives matter
you can walk out right now and start
your own black lives matter
so could i all right um and you have
certain factions that that consist of
black supremacists you have certain
factions that you got blacks and whites
working together
you got some that have more white people
than black people in
in in the thing called black lives
matter some some are factions
they want to just go out there and tear
stuff down and spray graffiti all over
the place
blm and then the others who want to sit
down with the state legislature
and try to work things out and say hey
look we need a bill
to pass this and this and we want to
work this out
so you got different ideas going around
nobody's on the same page
and then here's what happens with the
media let's say
um we're here in seminole
so let's say you have your black lives
matter chapter
and you're doing things the good way um
you're sitting you're sitting down with
your county uh legislature
trying to get some bills passed and and
you know you know amend some laws that
will
give equity to more people all right
which is good but then the largo chapter
uh or a faction of black lives matter
they're tearing up stuff
you know bashing up stuff and putting
graffiti all over the place
the media is gonna cover that and
they're not gonna say
the largo chapter of black lives matter
is doing blah blah blah
they're going to say black lives matter
so it paints a broad brush across all
the factions
right rather than distinguish each one
right
you see what i'm saying definitely so we
need more cohesion
and when you have all these different
factions and each faction has its own
little leader
and each little leader has different
ideas uh it's like having too many chefs
in the kitchen
trying to fix the same recipe it doesn't
work you know black lives matter is not
saying
you know they try to accuse it of
meaning you know only black lives matter
no um because you know you say black
lives matter
and they say no all lives matter well
yes all lives do matter but why do why
do black lives matter less
right you know and here's here's the
interesting thing
um
they they want to criticize black lives
matter
the same uh because
they feel it does not include white
lives
you know which is why they come back
with all lives matter
meaning my life matters too yes your
life does matter too
but they say that they don't want to say
black lives matter because it doesn't
include white lives
so they say all lives matter so they so
so so you support all lives matter yeah
absolutely
uh you support black lives matter no why
because it does not include white lives
okay so do you
do do you uh support blue lives matter
well yeah of course
back to blue yeah yeah well wait a
minute
how can you support blue lives matter
they don't say anything about white
lives either
so so your complaint is that the same
black lives matter says nothing about
white lives
so therefore you don't support it but
where where does it say anything about
white lives
when it says blue lives matter what's
the difference between black lives and
blue lives right
neither one of them mentions white lives
so how can you say you're gonna support
this one
yeah and i think that's the point of all
this right i mean that's that's the
basic the basic
moral of your story is that there needs
to be conversation there needs to be
open discourse there needs to be the
walls need to be brought down